as i was crying
out of nowhere i heard an audible voice
i heard the name jesus
and the only freedom that i found from
that
was only through jesus christ stop the
cap we challenge you if you want to do a
debate if you want to have a discourse
we're open we're not shying away from
any public discourse but you won't
instead you make these stupid videos and
ads and and pin them into muslim
channels you've been doing it to ali
you've
because i've seen your ads everywhere
but enough is enough
assalamu alaikum
welcome back to the religious reaction
channel in the donia before we go into
deconstructing this channel i just want
to give a quick reminder that tomorrow
my vlog from umrah does air and you know
i started a new channel there's gonna be
a lot of videos even with gabriel i went
to the desert in dubai so look forward
to those friday tomorrow you guys are
gonna get a little snippet on the main
channel and that's going to include a
link to the
new channel but you did see the a little
snippet what do you think about it so
far
it is beautiful like imagine umrah being
beautiful as beautiful as it is but to
record it and to edit it in such a
beautiful manner it is like pristine bro
i saw it and like bro my heart dropped
it was absolutely gorgeous masha'allah
and like bro if you guys want an iman
boost if you guys want motivation to
save up and go to umrah go to hajj watch
that video when it drops
bro just
i really do appreciate it and that's all
i want to do with this new channel that
i'm starting bro and especially with the
vlog if you guys want an iman booster
and you're thinking
watch that video tomorrow's the day
inshaallah with that being said let's go
into the video
i grew up in a muslim home all i ever
was taught growing up in houston was the
five pillars of faith of islam
that jesus was just a prophet and
basically if i did those five pillars of
faith to the best of my ability then
maybe uh i would get to heaven my senior
year in high school i became curious
of jesus i remember playing basketball
and taking the lord's name in vain i
just said jesus and a guy walks over to
me and he says hey that jesus you just
said
he's my god and i said no no he's not
he's not he's not the lord he's just a
prophet he goes no no he's lord he is
god in human form and i thought the guy
was nuts and so
i go home i said you know i think i got
a bible somewhere so i go upstairs to my
room and look all over my room and if
you can believe this
after 10 years i found it sitting at the
bottom of my closet waiting for me all
those years and i read the whole book of
matthew in one sitting i get to the book
of romans in the bible and it changed my
life and i started to see
the truth of the gospel
it said that this righteousness comes to
all who believe and see i thought i was
born a muslim i was stamped a muslim i'd
always be a muslim but that said for
anyone any race any ethnicity any nation
so a couple of weeks after that i'm at a
football practice and a guy invited me
to a christian event with a very funny
name it was called a crusade and i
looked at him and i go you know i'm a
muslim you're inviting me to a thing
called a crusade and he goes oh no it
has nothing to do with that
he said it's there's free pizza there
and i go oh i like free pizza so i went
and i heard the gospel preached
god opened my heart to belief and i put
my faith in jesus christ and everything
changed for me and i'm ashamed to say
this but for about a year and a half i
hid my faith from my father i would
sneak out to go to church
i'd hide my bible and finally one day my
dad found out and he said son what's
going on and i said well dad i'm a
christian
okay before we find out what father has
done no pun intended
am i the only one that's tripping on the
fact that he called it muslim
you're not the only one
muslim
bro if you were a muslim
you would not be unless you're a reaver
a fresh reaver you will not be saying
muslim this guy bro he said five pillars
of faith there are six pillars of faith
there are five people
yeah exactly why there are five pillars
of islam six pillars of iman so he
already messed that one up uh saying
muslim muslim and then what muslim born
and raised in a muslim household says
jesus in vain like
who says that which muslim
which muslim has a bible at the bottom
of their dresser that they had no idea
was there and then it went missing all
this time they finally found it under
all their their clothes and their socks
and stuff and then
red
reads all of matthew and then
revolutions just randomly random order
matthew revelations and then
bro this like just it's never based on
evidence it's never based on oh it was
proven to me
it logically sits well with me better
than islam it's always i put my faith in
my lord i put my faith into him i it was
a beautiful story he he killed himself
basically for me and now i believe
it's never based on logic
okay first thing yeah i agree bro
subhanallah this seems like one of those
idiots that like when you ask your
he's going to answer it
you know but anyway uh this book the 48
laws of power there's one of the laws in
the book called despise the free lunch
and i think this is very important to
say because
the free lunch is literally suscepting
vulnerable people
into luring whatever propaganda you want
to propagate and in the church figure in
the church culture i see a lot of stuff
like there's dancing there's wine
there's lunch there's food and it's very
appealing to people that just want a
sense of community and belongingness
that's one and number two christianity
to me rather seems like a religion of
convenience rather than conviction it's
almost like you could believe that jesus
god has stuck for allah and then no
matter what you do you're absolved from
that responsibility
yeah yeah exactly exactly and um people
like to argue that no you need to do
good work and this not the other paul
has specifically written uh that you
only need to put your faith in jesus
christ you only need to put your faith
and these sacrifices into jesus
basically
and um this is textbook like textbook
fake muslim or fake ex-muslim
like there's nothing about it like i'm
an honest person if there's one thing
about it that i thought was legit or
real i would have been honest everything
he said up into this point i'm like bro
this guy read islam wiki or wiki islam
and then
went ham on the script
and he said no you're not young man
you're a muslim and you'll always be a
muslim and i said dad the bible says if
i trust in christ alone for my salvation
then i'm a christian and i do
and my dad said afternoon if you're
going to be a christian then you can no
longer be my son
now here's a god i've known for a year
and a half
martial that's what you call a man right
there
here's my dad my my entire upbringing my
culture my hero
and so everything in me wanted to say
forget it i'll be a muslim
i didn't want to lose my dad even i was
surprised when i opened my mouth and
these words came out instead i said dad
if i have to choose between you and
jesus then i choose jesus and so my
father disowns me on the spot
and this is the definitive moment of my
life i fell on my knees and i said god
how could you do this to me i said jesus
if you're real how could you take my dad
away from me and i turned in the bible
to matthew
chapter 10. do not suppose i have come
to bring peace to the earth i didn't
cover any peace but a sword and then he
says this for i have come to turn a man
against his father and i'm reading this
going
whoa this just happened for me then
jesus says this whoever wants to save
his life will lose it but whoever loses
his life for my sake will find it
[Music]
my wife isn't the only person that's
been telling me about this for months
that
this channel has been putting their ads
in their propaganda on our youtube yes
our youtube channel our youtube is
flooded with a lot of ads from this
channel who's
they have a deep agenda to take our
viewers to take muslims to take people
that aren't too confined in or
consolidated in their faith and kind of
gear them towards this this newer more
relaxed more appealing religion of
christianity
yeah yeah and it's uh you'll find a
common theme with all them because
muslims even in the quran if they're
true to heart muslims right trudeau
muslims
they will know they have they will be
raised on you know if you if you claim
something bring your proofs even allah
says if you believe there are you know
lords or gods other than allah bring
your proof bring your evidence and
muslims are raised upon this right
muslims are are
taught that we have this fitrah to
believe in one god alone and everything
in the quran so we know we're based off
evidence we're logical people allah
mentions our
and those who reflect and ponder and use
their intelligence so a sound normal
muslim is not going to eventually turn
to someone that's like the bible says
this so it's true
and that's exactly what he did
he's like he he justified his
christianity that he justifies
christianity his father in this
real story a real um backstory he has
saying the bible says it
are you serious that's your
justification to your dad bro if this is
a true story that's why he disowned you
because you're illogical in your in your
belief
bro do you do you have some type of
brain cells remaining for the second
video
maybe half half of brain cells
let's make that zero now
you know when you're born into islam
that's your identity it's who you are
i was born and raised in amman jordan
for 14 years i grew up in
a pretty large conservative muslim very
traditional family i had a lot of
questions in regards to muhammad's life
and just the validity of the quran and
salvation was a big one for me i felt
like i could never keep up or measure up
to what was expected out of me and they
weren't too keen on me asking those
questions and you know they'd always say
no one knows but allah and that just
didn't really sit well with me
my father was an alcoholic ever since i
could remember and my earliest memory of
him was when i was five years old and
him kicking me to the ground and
spitting at me and calling me names that
no father should ever call his
five-year-old daughter
my home life continued to get worse in
jordan and my mother who's an american
was mortified she was afraid for her
life and our lives and my mom encouraged
my dad to bring us to america to better
our english for you know jobs down the
road or schooling and he agreed to so
they moved us from jordan to america in
the year of 2000 and when my dad would
come and visit his alcoholism just got
worse and worse that's when i met a boy
in high school and we fell in love and
it felt good to be loved by someone and
one thing led to another and i found
myself my parents bathroom floor holding
a positive pregnancy test at the age of
17.
had i gone to my dad
culturally um he would have murdered me
and i'm not just saying that
figuratively but that i mean she said
herself culturally but let's see what
she has to say
it was my reality he would have murdered
me and had i gone to my mom
she
would have told my dad and same thing
what happened so i didn't really have
anybody to confide in and the only
person that i confided in was the
boyfriend that i was dating at that time
and we felt like we didn't really have a
whole lot of options and the only option
like we felt we had was to go through
with an abortion
that was very hard for me because i've
always valued life i would daydream
about what it'd be like to hold my baby
one day and
to have gone through that was very
devastating for me and i struggled with
shame
embarrassment and
depression anxiety and self-worth
and i was trying to fill that pain in
that void in my life with things of this
world that just made that pain and that
void in my life so much bigger and i was
just going down a dangerous dark and
downward spiral in life
i knew that my sins were deemed
unforgivable in islam and i knew that i
was so extremely hated by
rami what rami rami please please
enlighten us she knew that her sins were
deemed unforgivable in islam please
allah says in the quran whoever
commits a sin
or whoever is you know committing his
sin and then remembers allah and then
repents soon after
allah will forgive them basically and
the scholars they say that
um
basically well allah mentions ignorance
in this right in the scholars they say
that anyone who commits a sin commits it
in a state of ignorance because had they
not been ignorant they wouldn't have
done the sin because no one's sitting
there sitting thinking oh allah is
watching me i'm sinning i'm you know
so anyone who does any sin in a state of
ignorance and then soon after repents
and turns to allah will be forgiven the
scholars interpret soon after to mean
before their death so no matter what you
do as long as you repent in this life
you will be forgiven for it so there are
so many problems with what she said all
throughout her story and like honestly i
don't doubt that it's real i don't doubt
that it's a legit story
especially because she what she says has
nothing to do with islam alcoholism
allah prohibits alcoholism beating
allah prohibits beating and specifically
the process of sodom commanded us to be
good to our women not just our wives but
our daughters and the women in our lives
so alcoholism beating
what's it called um what's the term
completely haram in islam this has
literally no roots in islam nothing she
mentioned was islamic the only thing
that was close to it was were scholars
saying no one knows about allah which is
not that's not what the scholars say
they give you an answer and they say but
allah knows best which is true
which you say even i was christian you
would say god knows best so
i mean i doubt i i don't doubt that her
story is real but it has literally
nothing to do with islam and you
mentioned it
that she said culturally what you do
culturally they have a culture it's not
islamic but how do you feel about this
i agree 100 000 bro and it's always a
story about someone that was never put
on deemed properly never had the right
o'clock in their family those leading
with righteous examples and they fall
emotionally victim out of islam and
towards something more accepting in a
world with nufs in a world telling you
body positivity and acceptance and this
and off of the people and just follow
your notes make them your god and i
understand why this lady and people like
her
are leaving islam when they're not put
on it properly when they misconstrue
a religion of truth with this
controlling thing this controlling
narrative that they put on by their
family yeah
but if a world of of i guess
false lies and just living in a fool's
paradise appeals to you and that's the
way you want to die then
i can't stop you i mean i can't i can do
my best but at the end of it so it's all
up to you
yeah that's facts that's facts you know
her her her family her community as you
said bro they failed her if those
scholars truly did say something like
that they failed her they failed as as
leaders in that community and this is
why we need good strong muslim leaders
and teachers and scholars to actually
teach and lead the community so they can
grow up to be teachers and leaders so
things like this don't happen and again
i'm going to say for the third time i
honestly believe her story is true but
if she was a practicing muslim none of
that would have happened if her family
were practicing she wouldn't have been
abused her dad wouldn't have been
alcoholic she wouldn't have insha allah
wouldn't have committed zinna she
wouldn't have even thought about going
near a christian guy for it to even you
know for there to even be a chance of
them uh dating and committing in the end
because allah says don't go anywhere
near zina don't go anywhere near it and
the problem i said i would i would say
the biggest downfall in her life in that
story was when she decided to go away
from allah and commit zinna
that was when her life really started
falling apart
and that's when she
went further and further and further in
the darkness and eventually went to
paganism essentially worshipping a man
stuck for allah
allah and at that time i was trying to
search for some form of forgiveness and
hope and that's when i went to the quran
actually opened the quran and and i
stumbled upon suda 4 168 through 169 and
it goes something like this i'm kind of
paraphrasing it but allah does not
forgive those who reject the faith and
do wrong and that he doesn't lead them
to into a better path and the only path
that he leads him to is to hell and i
remember reading that and just feeling
so much fear and
hopelessness
i said allah i don't know who you are i
don't even know if you exist and telling
him i've been praying to you for 20 some
years and i've never felt your presence
and
crying and just thinking of ways how i
can end my life because if there's no
form of forgiveness for me in islam then
what's the point of me living and
as i was crying
out of nowhere i heard an audible voice
i heard the name jesus
so i you know looked up to the heavens
and i opened my hands and had tears
going down my face and i said jesus i'm
like i don't know who you are but if you
are who you say you are please reveal
yourself to me because i can't go on
living life like this anymore
and that was the first time ever from
praying that i ever felt any form of
peace
the boyfriend that i was dating he and i
broke up and i met a young man who was
just so different from anyone that i'd
ever met very loving and it intrigued me
and we started dating and um
i was in his house one day and found i
saw that he had a bible an open bible on
his desk and i remember thinking oh like
i'm dating a christian and shortly
thereafter i met his parents
i just remember observing them and just
thinking you know they have love they
have this joy they have this peace and
this freedom and it's like i want i've
always wanted what they had and i
remember thinking they have jesus in
their lives
i approached him and i asked him if he
would take me to church church was great
but i felt like i needed a little bit
more so i asked him if his grandparents
would do bible studies with me
i remember textbook clinical psychology
symptoms of lying
all over body language bro i can i can
do a whole episode just deconstructing
this but why would i reading romans 5 8
for the first time but god proves his
love for us in that while we were still
sinners christ died for us god's love
for us is not a response to our goodness
but in spite of our lack of goodness and
and at that moment i realize how
different it is being a muslim from
being a christian that's when i decided
to be baptized and become a follower of
jesus
for years i lived with a lot of anger
towards my dad four years ago he was
binge drinking and was dying and
i prayed to the lord that he would
soften my heart towards my dad and i'd
ask him if he can help me see him the
way he sees him and
i was on the phone with my dad and i
said baba jesus loves you
you could spend eternity with him and us
one day and he
bro i'm trying
for you and your sins
are forgiven if you give your life to
him i said bubba do you receive christ
into your life
i was expecting no but he was an op with
a big yes he said yes i do
and i was so excited to hear that and
he said i'm so excited you know to see
you guys one day and i said it's not
gonna feel like we're gonna be apart for
too long
fear of muslim i would say
there's a verse john 10 10 where god
says you know i've come to give them
life and to give them life
in fullness you know the abundant love
that he has for all of us is there's
nothing like it and i know that he wants
muslims to experience that and more
you know i lived with so much shame with
so much condemnation with
all these things that just weighed me
down all these years and the only
freedom that i found from that
was only through jesus christ
bro oh my god
okay bro i found the truth is that
satirical because you found lies what
yes
i take it back bro that was definitely a
lie the first part may be true i don't
know i don't care that last part is
definitely a lie allah says in the quran
[Music]
tell my servants
who have transgressed against themselves
by sinning
do not despair do not lose hope in the
mercy of allah
indeed allah forgives all sins
and it is him who is the most forgiving
and the most merciful if you had read
the quran you would have found
forgiveness and mercy all over it if you
would have read
literally
the what you read before you start
actually reading the quran the bismillah
the most gracious the most merciful you
would have known allah is merciful if
you would have read
the second verse in the first chapter
after alhamdulillah
you would have read
again
again
if you made it through the quran you
would have found verse after verse after
verse after verse of forgiveness and
what she did to herself at the end of
her story was just condemn herself
because even the verse she quoted said
those who disbelieve
if you believe you'll be that that
implies that if you believe and ask for
forgiveness you'll be forgiven because
the difference is one believes one
doesn't it's very clear cut but that's
bro this is why i doubt these stories to
be true heavily one islam muslim
it's
binge drinking cultural oppression
they're saying islam bro
and if you guys did for some reason find
out our video i'm talking to the channel
right now those of you that are
spreading this propaganda i've found the
truth or whatever you're called
we challenge you if you want to do a
debate if you want to have a discourse
we're open we're not shying away from
any public discourse but you won't
instead you make these stupid videos and
ads and pin them into muslim channels
you've been doing it while you've been
doing to muhammad hijab because i've
seen your ads everywhere
but enough is enough if you really want
to take it to the next level let's go
yeah
we formally challenge you to a debate
get over here you're finished
you are finished
[Laughter]
i feel like
bro yeah i feel like there is so much i
was going to say about the story but
honestly a lot of this tipped my mind i
don't think it's like it's not worth it
at this point you know what i mean it's
like it's like dissecting a fairy tale
at this point it's like okay
yeah but
type
i mean
how much your second say bro at this
point all right and we'll end it there
with that being said
if you guys made it this far
comment down below hashtag
you didn't find the truth
but if only then you
and uh until next time look forward to
the vlog once again tomorrow live stream
tomorrow as well 11am eastern standard
time you already know what the deal is
that's crazy because
y'all know how like impactful it was
yeah isn't it if you're watching this it
was so
it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subanaly i think it's crazy
um
[Music]
[Music]
you